yes they was the first half of a
two-parter this is the second half we
wanted to be able to graph parabolas
we've graph parabolas before but we're
going to look at harder parabolas and
we're going to be more precise about
them we're going to get more detail okay
so this was actually one of the first
problems I asked you to do and we went
through step by step I actually can't
remember what the equation is but it's
not important to me right now well I
want to remind you of was this what I
want to remind you of is we found these
two values can some actually turn back a
page and tell me what was this value
here I think it was maybe eight nine
nine I was close okay and then I said to
you by the way it's important that you
know where the parabola turns around
what's the special name at that point
it's the vertex it's important that you
put the vertex in the right spot that
you don't put it say on the nine or on
the right-hand side of the nine it has
to be on the left do you remember how we
came up with it how did we know it had
to be on that side we said it had to be
in the middle of the parabola right
parabolas are symmetrical and so since
it's sort of pushed over to the left the
vertex is also sort of pushed over to
the left now what we didn't do yesterday
was have a careful look at well what if
you don't want to do it just roughly
right what if you actually want to
precisely know okay and what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to call you back to the
quadratic equation sorry the quadratic
formula which we wrote five minutes ago
but please note this I want you to write
it a slightly different way to normal
please write it like this
okay this is the quadratic formula
you've seen it before we looked at it
five minutes ago okay but I've done
something a bit unusual instead of
writing it as a single fraction with one
denominator I've written it as two
fractions with two denominators that are
the same okay now tell me on an equation
like say this if I when it did the
quadratic formula what does this tell me
about this which numbers does it give me
if you went through this process you put
it a and B and C you're gonna get some
stuff down the bottom x equals something
what are those something's yeah I've
actually labeled them on here what are
the numbers you're gonna get these
numbers right you're gonna get these
numbers so these give you the
x-intercepts okay now what I want you to
notice is and if you've drawn this it's
gonna be here need to do this next part
in another color what I want you to
notice is Ryan you're at great what I
want you to notice is if you put on to
here the axis of symmetry like I showed
you before let's just draw it as a
dotted line straight down the middle do
you see that you'll find the x
intercepts both sides of the axis right
here's the axis in the middle one root
you'll find on the right and the other
root you'll find on the left and because
it's symmetrical they have to be the
same distance apart does that make sense
can you see it's sort of reflected
across now mark this put your PIN down
just so you can watch this moment see
this go to the right go to the left that
way that way there's an algebraic
meaning in here that tells you you go to
the right you're going to left on the
x-axis which direction is positive to
the right that is positive which means
of course that which direction is
negative to the left so now I want you
to look at the quadratic formula to find
the x-intercepts you start from some
middle point you go plus
some distance to get one of the
x-intercepts and then you go - the same
distance to find your other x-intercept
so therefore looking at the formula
which is the bit in the middle where's
the point you start from and then go
either way
it's the vertex is gonna lie on this
middle part which is this do you see
that here's like some number suppose it
ends up being well actually in this case
I'm pretty sure it's minus three over
four okay
actually we can check that it's minus
three over four halfway between minus
three three 1/2 yeah there you go
no it's negative look it's on the
left-hand side ok so no no no once you
once you've evaluated the whole number
if you get minus three over four there
is the middle this is the axis and this
tells you go to the left and the right
if you go the same distance away this
distance here that I've drawn in green
you get to your x-intercepts on either
side okay so therefore what we can take
from the quadratic formula is x equals
just the front part just that guy that
is the axis okay so if you want to find
the middle of the parabola this part
here you punch in these numbers okay now
I will ask you to help me this was y
equals what was the actual equation was
at minus two x squared I'm trying to
remember plus nine oh sorry
yep okay so in order to find this axis I
could look and say oh it's halfway but I
can go straight to finding what the axis
is by looking at this okay in this case
what's be look carefully really it's the
whole number it's minus 3 so minus minus
3 that's minus B okay all on to a what a
it's the whole number which is minus 2 2
times a there's a lot of negatives there
let's work out what's going on I'm gonna
cancel negative from the top and the
bottom right that's a - sorry it's messy
my bad quadratics
how many negatives you're left with on
the top just one what are you left with
on the bottom 2 times 2 which is 4 which
is what we said earlier one last note
which is really important what's super
useful about this is you can use this
regardless of whether you have
x-intercepts or not do you remember we
said yesterday this gives you X
intercepts but you might not have any
you might have 0 x-intercepts or 1 this
parabola would have exactly one
x-intercept and this one has none it
never actually touches the x-axis at all
okay but you can still use this you can
always use this you always have an axis
of symmetry on a parabola because a
parabola is always symmetrical ya know
so I asked you yesterday actually how
can it be that sometimes you get no
x-intercepts sometimes you get one
sometimes you get two but you always
always always get a y-intercept here's
why you don't need to draw this but put
a parabola anywhere you like okay
suppose I put a parabola here
the part that I've drawn of this
parabola it doesn't touch the y-axis
does it so it doesn't look like it has a
y-intercept but that's only because I
haven't drawn the whole thing that's
what arrows mean right arrows mean they
keep going okay if I went far enough
eventually there would be some point
down there off my whiteboard where they
would intersect okay
you can't ever make the parabola stop
it'll collide somewhere okay so that's
why you always get one